- Maligayang pagbabalik sa Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation.
Ako si John Watrous, at ako ang technical director
ng Education sa IBM Quantum.
Ito ang ikalawang aralin ng serye. Kung hindi mo pa
napanood ang unang aralin, siguraduhing tingnan mo ito.
Direkta kaming magtatayo sa mga napag-usapan natin
sa unang aralin, kaya mahalaga na maintindihan mo
ang materyal na iyon bago pumasok sa araling ito.
Gayundin, tandaan na ang serye
ay may kasamang nilalaman ng textbook bukod sa mga video, at makakakita ka ng link
sa nilalaman ng textbook
sa paglalarawan ng video. Ito ang aralin dalawa ng
unit isa ng serye.
Sinasaklaw ng unit isa ang mga pangunahing kaalaman
ng quantum information.
Sa nakaraang aralin, napag-usapan natin ang quantum information sa konteksto ng mga solong sistema, ibig sabihin mayroon tayong isang
sistema na nag-iimbak ng impormasyon
at inilarawan natin kung paano
ito gumagana nang mag-isa.
Naglagi tayo ng mahabang panahon sa
classical information, pangunahin upang maitatag ang isang punto ng sanggunian at upang maipakita ang
mga pagkakatulad sa matematika
sa pagitan ng quantum at classical information.
Nakita rin natin kung paano maaaring kinatawan ang mga quantum state ng mga vector, partikular ang mga vector na may
mga entry na complex number at Euclidean norm na katumbas ng isa,
at napag-usapan natin ang mga standard
basis measurement at unitary operation.
Sa araling ito, palawakin natin ang ating
pananaw sa maraming sistema, bawat isa ay kayang
mag-imbak ng quantum information.
Hindi ito simpleng pagsasabi na ang bawat indibidwal na sistema
ay gumagana tulad ng napag-usapan natin noong nakaraan, may kahulugan kung saan ang kabuuan
ay mas malaki kaysa sa kabuuan ng mga bahagi, at totoo rin iyon sa
classical information kapag may kinalaman ang mga probabilidad.
Ang maraming sistema ay maaaring
makipag-ugnayan sa isa't isa at maaari silang mag-ugnayan
sa isa't isa halimbawa, at sa quantum setting, kasama rito ang posibilidad
na ang mga sistema ay entangled, na isang termino na
maaaring narinig mo na noon.
Ang entanglement ay isang napaka-
mahalagang penomenon sa quantum information at marami pa tayong masasabi tungkol dito habang nagpapatuloy ang serye.
Mayroong isang simpleng prinsipyo, gayunpaman, na nagbibigay sa atin ng malaking tulong sa pag-iisip at
pag-unawa sa quantum information para sa maraming sistema,
at iyon ay lagi tayong makaka-
kuha ng dalawa o higit pang sistema at pagsamahin ang mga ito o isipin lamang ang mga ito nang magkasama
at tingnan ang mga ito na parang bumubuo sila
ng isang solong compound system.
At kapag nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa isang
compound system na ganito, na parang ito ay isang solong sistema, kinikilala natin na dapat itong ilarawan sa paraang pare-pareho
sa lahat ng natutunan natin
sa nakaraang aralin tungkol sa mga solong sistema.
Makikita natin kung paano ito gumagana
at kung paano ang paglalarawan ng quantum information
para sa maraming sistema ay natural na lumalabas mula sa kung paano ito gumagana para sa mga solong sistema
batay sa isang prinsipyong ito. Narito ang pangkalahatang-ideya ng aralin at ito ay kapareho ng pangkalahatang-ideya ng nakaraang aralin,
ngunit sa pagkakataong ito ang ating pokus
ay nasa maraming sistema sa halip na mga solong sistema.
Tulad ng ginawa natin sa nakaraang aralin at para sa eksaktong parehong mga dahilan, magsisimula tayo sa
classical information.
Muli, makikita natin
ang napakalapit na pagkakatulad sa pagitan ng paraan ng pagtatrabaho ng quantum
at classical information sa antas ng matematika.
Hindi tayo karaniwang magtutuon nang gayon
karaming oras sa classical information o magsisimula ng bawat aralin sa serye sa classical information na ganito.
Ang mga susunod na aralin ay magiging mas eksklusibong nakatuon sa quantum information at computation.
Ngunit dito sa simula
ito ay isang makatwirang diskarte at bumabalik ito sa ideya na ang pag-iisip tungkol sa classical information
ay maaaring magsilbing mahalagang pinagkukunan ng gabay para sa pag-unawa sa quantum information.
Pag-uusapan din natin
ang mahalagang konsepto ng tensor product sa
bahaging ito ng aralin.
Ang mga tensor product ay kritikal na mahalaga sa quantum information, ngunit lumilitaw din sila sa
classical setting.
Pagkatapos ay lilipat tayo sa quantum information at tulad ng sa nakaraang aralin tatalakayin natin ang mga quantum state,
standard basis measurement,
at unitary operation sa pagkakataong ito
para sa maraming sistema.
Magsisimula tayo sa pag-uusap
tungkol sa mga classical state ng maraming sistema.
Alalahanin mula sa nakaraang
aralin na ang isang classical state ng isang sistema ay isang
configuration ng sistemang iyon na maaaring makilala at
maialarawan nang walang kalabuan
nang walang anumang kawalan ng katiyakan o pagkakamali. At sa mga terminong matematikal, kapag tinutukoy natin ang isang classical state set,
ibig sabihin nito ay isang finite at hindi walang laman na set.
Sisimulan natin ang ating talakayan
ng maraming sistema sa pamamagitan ng pagpapalagay na mayroon tayong
dalawang sistema lamang na X at Y.
Ang X ay may ilang set ng mga classical state na tatawagin nating sigma tulad
ng sa nakaraang aralin, at ang Y ay may ilang set ng mga classical state
na tatawagin nating gamma. Ang set na sigma at gamma
ay maaaring parehong set o maaaring iba,
ngunit binibigyan natin sila ng iba't ibang pangalan, hindi lamang dahil
maaari silang maging iba't ibang set, kundi dahil makakatulong din
sa atin na panatilihing malinaw ang mga bagay kung bibigyan natin sila ng iba't ibang pangalan.
Mahahanap natin na medyo madaling pangkalahatanin ang buong talakayan na ito mula sa dalawang sistema patungo sa anumang bilang ng mga sistema, ngunit
sa pamamagitan ng pagsisimula sa dalawang sistema,
maaari tayong magtuon sa mga pangunahing ideya nang hindi nalulubog sa mga detalye.
Ngayon, isipin na inilalagay natin
ang X at Y sa tabi-tabi na may X sa kaliwa at Y sa kanan, at tinitingnan natin ang dalawang sistemang ito nang magkasama
na parang bumubuo sila ng isang solong compound system.
upang bigyan ng pangalan ang bagong sistemang ito, maaari nating isulat ito bilang isang
ordered pair na ganito, o maaari nating ilagay lamang
ang dalawang titik na ganito.
Pareho itong karaniwan at maaari
tayong pumili kung alin ang gusto natin o kung alin ang mas maginhawa.
Kahit papaano, babasahin natin ito bilang XY.
Isang napaka-natural na tanong
na dapat itanong sa puntong ito ay ano ang mga classical state ng bagong compound system na XY?
At ang sagot sa tanong na iyon ay ang classical state set ng XY ay ang Cartesian product ng
dalawang classical state set,
sigma at gamma, na makikita mo
itong tinukoy dito mismo.
Sa isang partikular na sandali, ang X ay may ilang classical state
na isang elemento ng sigma, at ang Y ay may ilang classical state
na isang elemento ng gamma,
at simpleng iniisip natin
ang dalawang estado na ito nang magkasama na parang bumubuo sila ng isang estado, at iyon mismo ang nosyon
na kinukuha ng Cartesian product. Mayroon tayong dalawang elemento,
isa mula sa bawat isa sa ating mga set, at gusto nating isipin ang
dalawang elementong ito nang magkasama
na parang bumubuo sila ng isang solong
elemento mula sa isang solong set.
Upang maging malinaw, mayroong isang pagpapalagay dito na alam natin
kung alin sa ating mga sistema ang X at kung alin ang Y,
at walang kalituhan sa pagitan nila. Hindi mahalaga na ang X ay pisikal na nasa kaliwang kamay
na bahagi at ang Y ay nasa kanan,
kundi ang dalawang
sistema ay nakikilala at napagpasyahan nating
ayusin ang mga ito sa ganitong paraan upang mapanatili nating
malinaw kung alin ang alin.
Narito ang isang napaka-simpleng halimbawa kung saan ang sigma ay ang binary alphabet at ang gamma ay ang set
na naglalaman ng apat na suit ng baraha.
Kung nag-iimbak ang X ng binary value at nag-iimbak ang Y ng isa sa apat na suit ng baraha, mayroon itong walong
posibleng classical state
ng pares na XY, na makikita mo
na nakalista dito mismo.
Para sa higit sa dalawang sistema, ito ay napangkalahatang sa isang simpleng paraan.
Partikular kung ang X1 hanggang Xn ay mga sistema na may mga classical
state set na sigma isa hanggang sigma n ayon sa pagkakasunud-sunod.
Kung iisipin natin ang pagpapangkat
ng n na sistema nang magkasama at tinitingnan ang mga ito bilang isang sistema, ang classical state set ay
ibinibigay ng Cartesian product
ng n na classical state set
na sigma isa hanggang sigma n.
Gaya ng makikita mo dito sa screen. Ang Cartesian product
ay maaaring tukuyin na ganito para sa anumang bilang ng mga set.
Halimbawa, kung mayroon tayong tatlong sistema at lahat sila ay nagbabahagi ng binary alphabet bilang kanilang classical state set, kaya sa madaling salita mayroon tayong tatlong bit,
mayroon itong walong
posibleng classical state ng tatlong bit na tiningnan
nang magkasama bilang isang solong sistema at makikita mo ang mga ito na nakalista dito mismo.
Bawat sistema nang mag-isa ay maaaring
nasa estado zero o isa, at sumasaklaw tayo sa lahat ng
posibleng kombinasyon.
Ang isang n-tuple ng mga classical state ay maaaring alternatibong isulat bilang isang string kung saan inaalis natin ang
mga panaklong at kuwit gaya ng makikita mo dito mismo.
At ito ay partikular na makatuwiran kapag iniisip natin ang
mga classical state bilang mga simbolo tulad ng sa napaka-karaniwang halimbawa
ng binary alphabet
na paulit-ulit nating binabalik. Minsan napaka-maginhawa nitong gawin at malamang na gawing mas simple
ang ating mga ekspresyon
at hindi masyadong makalat. Ang nosyon ng isang string ay talagang pormal
sa mga terminong matematikal sa pamamagitan ng mga Cartesian product,
kaya ito ay talagang isang
alternatibong notasyon at hindi isang bagay na naiiba sa konsepto.
Bilang halimbawa, sabihin nating mayroon tayong
sampung bit na X1 hanggang X10.
Ibig sabihin nito ang classical state set ng sampung bit nang magkasama,
na maaari mong natural na isipin bilang isang sampung bit na register
sa isang computer halimbawa,
ay ang sampung beses na Cartesian
product ng binary alphabet sa sarili nito.
At kung susulatin natin ang mga estadong iyon bilang mga string, ganito ang hitsura ng mga ito dito, mayroon itong 1,024 na mga ito,
kaya siyempre hindi lahat sila nakalista dito. Ang tatlong tuldok na ito dito
ay dapat magpahiwatig na may pattern na maaari mong alamin
at sana ay naiintindihan mo ang ideya. Ngayon may isang kombensyon
na susundin natin para sa pag-order ng mga elemento
ng mga Cartesian product set,
at mahalaga itong
linawin para sa kapakanan ng paglalarawan ng kapwa probabilistic state at quantum state bilang mga vector.
Ang kombensyon ay ini-order natin ang mga elemento ng Cartesian product
set lexicographically, na karaniwang nangangahulugang pag-order ng diksyunaryo.
Upang maging mas tiyak, nagsisimula tayo sa pagpapalagay na ang bawat isa sa mga indibidwal na set na kinukuha natin ang Cartesian product nito ay mayroon nang sariling pag-order
at iniisip natin ang isang
partikular na n-tuple o isang string na parang ito ay isang salita at ini-order natin ang mga ito nang alpabetiko.
Isa pang paraan upang sabihin ito ay ang mga posisyon sa loob ng
isang n-tuple o isang string ay bumababa ang kahalagahan
mula kaliwa patungo sa kanan,
tulad ng kapag nagsusulat tayo ng mga numero gamit ang mga digit zero hanggang siyam.
Narito ang isang halimbawa na
nilayong linawin ito.
Kung kukunin natin ang Cartesian product sa pagitan ng mga set na naglalaman ng
isa, dalawa, at tatlo at ng binary alphabet, makakakuha tayo ng set na naglalaman ng anim na elemento
at narito ang mga ito na nakalista sa
order na inilalarawan.
Lahat ng mga elemento na may
isa sa unang posisyon ay nauuna bago ang lahat ng mga elemento na may dalawa sa unang posisyon at nauuna sila bago ang lahat ng mga elemento
na may tatlo sa unang posisyon. At kapag ang dalawang elemento
ay nagkakasundo sa unang posisyon, bumabalik tayo sa pag-order
sa ikalawang posisyon.
Iyon ang pag-order na
ginagamit natin para sa mga Cartesian product.
Pansinin na kapag ginagamit natin ang kombensyong ito at isinusulat natin ang n-tuple bilang mga string, napansin natin ang ilang napaka-pamilyar na pattern.
Halimbawa, ang Cartesian product ng
binary alphabet sa sarili nito ay ino-order gaya ng makikita mo dito,
at maaari mong isipin ang mga string na ito bilang ino-order nang numeriko kung ituturing mo ang mga string na ito
bilang mga binary encoding ng mga hindi-negatibong halo at ito ay napangkalahatang
sa anumang haba ng string. Pagpapatuloy sa mga probabilistic state, alam na natin mula sa nakaraang aralin
na ang isang probabilistic state ay nagbibigay ng probabilidad sa bawat classical
state ng isang partikular na sistema.
Kung mayroon tayong compound system kung saan kinuha natin ang dalawa o higit pang sistema at tinitingnan ang mga ito nang kolektibo na parang bumubuo sila ng isang solong
sistema tulad ng talakayin natin,
ang isang probabilistic state
ng compound system na ito ay kailangang magtalaga ng mga probabilidad sa mga elemento ng Cartesian product
ng mga indibidwal na sistema,
mga classical state set. Iyon ay dahil iyon ang
classical state set ng compound system.
Halimbawa, ipagpalagay na
ang X at Y ay mga bit, mayroon tayong halimbawang ito ng isang
probabilistic state ng XY.
Ang probabilidad na parehong
bit ay zero ay isang kalahati at ang probabilidad na parehong
bit ay isa ay isang kalahati, at kaya ang dalawang bit ay hindi kailanman nagtatalo.
Ito ay isang wastong probabilistic state ng XY, at maaari nating alternatibong
isulat ito bilang isang vector
gaya ng makikita mo dito at dito maaari mong makita na
sinusunod natin ang kombensyon na inilarawan ko sandali lang ang nakalipas para sa pag-order ng mga classical state na ito.
Ito ay isang halimbawa ng
isang probabilistic state kung saan ang X at Y ay correlated, at ito ang kahulugan kung saan ang kabuuan
ay mas malaki kaysa sa kabuuan ng mga bahagi. Gaya ng aking iminungkahi dati, hindi simpleng mayroon tayong probabilistic state
ng X at isang probabilistic state ng Y at pinagsama natin ang mga ito, kundi una nating pinagsama
ang mga sistema
at pagkatapos ay iniisip natin ang
mga probabilistic state ng compound system.
Upang maging mas tiyak tungkol sa
mga ugnayan sa pagitan ng mga sistema. Nagsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng pagtukoy ng
nosyon ng kalayaan, na karaniwang ang
kawalan ng ugnayan.
Dito sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ang termino na kalayaan ay tumutukoy
sa statistical independence kumpara sa linear independence
ng mga vector halimbawa.
Ito ay pangunahing nosyon sa
probability at statistics.
Kung mayroon tayong dalawang sistema na X at Y at mayroon tayong ilang probabilistic
state ng XY sa isip, sinasabi nating ang X at Y ay malaya.
Kung ang formula na
makikita mo dito ay totoo para sa bawat pagpili ng mga classical
state na a at b ng X at Y.
Isang paraan upang bigyang-kahulugan ang
kondisyong ito ng kalayaan ay sinasabi nito na ang probabilidad para sa X na nasa anumang isang classical state
at ang probabilidad para sa Y na nasa ibang classical state ay wala talagang
kaugnayan sa isa't isa.
Kaya ang pag-aaral kung anong estado
ang isa sa mga sistema ay hindi nakakaapekto sa
mga probabilidad na nauugnay sa mga estado ng isa pang sistema.
Kung isipin mong random na pinipili
ang ilang classical state ng X ayon sa ilang pamamaraan at pagkatapos ay random na pinipili
ang ilang classical state ng Y
ayon sa ilang ibang pamamaraan na hindi sa anumang paraan
konektado sa isa para sa X, tulad ng kung ang isang tao ay nagbabato ng barya
at ang isa pang tao sa isang
iba pang silid ay nagtatapon ng dais, ang formula
na gagamitin mo upang makuha ang mga probabilidad
para sa iba't ibang kombinasyon
ng mga estado na lilitaw. Ang punto ng kahulugan ay ang kalayaan ay
kapag ang formula ay wasto.
Kapag iniisip natin ang mga probabilistic state sa pamamagitan ng mga probability vector, mayroong isang simpleng formulasyon
ng kondisyong ito
partikular kung mayroon tayong isang
probabilistic state ng XY, na maaari nating ipahayag bilang isang
vector sa direct notation
gaya ng makikita mo dito. Pagkatapos ay ang sabihing ang X at Y ay malaya ay katumbas ng pag-iral
ng dalawang probability vector,
cat Phi at cat Psi na sa pamamagitan ng paraan ay maaari nating
simpleng basahin bilang Phi at Psi para sa kapakanan ng kaiklian na kumakatawan
sa mga probabilistic state ng X at Y nang hiwalay na nagsisiyasat ng pagkakapantay-pantay na ito
na makikita mo dito.
Para sa lahat ng pagpili ng a at b, ito ay karaniwang isang
muling pagbabago ng kahulugan sa pamamagitan ng mga vector.
Halimbawa, narito ang isang probabilistic
state ng isang pares ng mga bit na XY kung saan ang X at Y ay malaya.
Ang kondisyon na
kinakailangan para sa kalayaan ay totoo para sa mga vector
na makikita mo dito.
Iyon ay ang probabilidad
para sa bawat posibleng setting para sa dalawang bit ay ibinibigay ng produkto ng mga katumbas na probabilidad
para sa mga indibidwal na bit.
Halimbawa, ang probabilidad para sa parehong
bit na kumuha ng halaga zero ay katumbas ng isang-anim, na katumbas ng isang-apat na beses ng dalawang-tatlo,
at gayundin para sa
tatlo pang posibilidad na maaaring suriin nang isa-isa.
Para sa probabilistic state na nakita natin kanina sa kabilang banda kung saan mayroon
tayong dalawang bit na laging nagkakasundo at kumukuha ng mga halaga zero at
isa na may probabilidad na isang kalahati
wala tayong kalayaan at iyon ang dahilan kung bakit sinasabi nating
ang mga bit ay correlated.
Ang correlation ay simpleng nangangahulugang
kawalan ng kalayaan.
Isang simpleng paraan upang patunayan na ang
dalawang bit ay hindi malaya ay ipagpalagay na sila ay at makuha ang isang kontradiksyon
partikular kung ang dalawang
bit ay malaya, dapat ay mayroon
mga numerong q0, q1, r0 at r1
na kumakatawan sa mga probabilidad
para sa dalawang indibidwal na bit upang ang mga ekwasyong
ito dito ay matupad.
Ang mga ito ang mga probabilidad
na nagmumula sa ating vector at ang mga ito ang
mga ekwasyon na dapat totoo sa pamamagitan ng kondisyon ng kalayaan,
ngunit kung titingnan natin ang
ikalawang pagkakapantay-pantay dito, makikita natin na hinihiling nito na
ang q0 na beses ng r1 ay katumbas ng zero,
ngunit ang tanging paraan na ang
produkto ng dalawang tunay na numero ay posibleng katumbas ng zero ay kung ang kahit isa sa mga
numerong iyon mismo ay katumbas ng zero.
Minsan tinatawag itong
zero product property ng mga tunay na numero.
Isa pang paraan upang sabihin ito ay ang produkto ng dalawang hindi-zero na tunay
na numero ay palaging hindi-zero.
Kaya ang pagkakapantay-pantay na ito
dito ay nagpapahiwatig na alinman sa q0 ay katumbas ng zero o ang r1 ay katumbas ng zero,
ngunit mula sa una at huli na mga pagkakapantay-pantay makikita natin na wala sa
dalawang alternatibong iyon ang maaaring totoo.
Kung ang q0 ay katumbas ng zero, ang produktong ito ay dapat katumbas ng zero, ngunit hindi ito katumbas ng zero
at kung ang r1 ay katumbas ng zero,
ang produktong ito ay dapat katumbas ng zero, ngunit hindi rin iyon totoo.
Kaya mayroon tayong kontradiksyon
at nagtatapos tayo na ang X at Y ay hindi malaya kaya sila ay correlated.
Ang nosyon ng kalayaan
na talakayin natin at partikular ang formulasyon nito sa pamamagitan ng mga probability
vector ay malapit na konektado
sa isang operasyon na maaaring
isagawa sa mga vector na kilala bilang tensor product.
Ang mga tensor product ay maaaring
tukuyin hindi lamang para sa mga vector kundi pati na rin para sa mga matrice
at sa katunayan ang nosyon ng tensor product ay maaaring tukuyin
para sa maraming iba pang uri ng
mga bagay sa matematika.
Maaari silang ilarawan
sa isang medyo abstract na paraan na parehong mahalaga at
kapaki-pakinabang sa purong matematika, ngunit maaari rin nating tukuyin
ang mga tensor product para sa mga vector
sa isang napaka-simple at konkreto na paraan, at iyon ang landas na
gagawin natin sa araling ito.
Kung mayroon tayong dalawang column vector na Phi at Psi na nakasulat sa mga form na makikita mo dito kung saan ang sigma at gamma ay alinmang
pagpili ng mga classical state set
na gusto natin o mga index kung mas gusto mo, ang tensor product ng mga vector na ito ay ang vector na makikita mo dito mismo.
Sumasaklaw tayo sa lahat ng elemento
ng Cartesian product ng dalawang set, sigma at gamma, at ang entry ng vector na ito na katumbas
sa bawat pares na ab, na
nakasulat bilang isang string dito, ay katumbas ng produkto ng
mga katumbas na entry
ng dalawang vector na ito. Sa madaling salita, ang ab entry ng Phi tensor Psi ay ang produkto ng a entry
ng Phi at ng b entry ng Psi,
at iyon ang kahulugan ng
nakasulat dito.
Sa esensya, ito ang parehong operasyon na nakita natin sandali lang ang nakalipas kapag tinalakay natin ang kalayaan
at ngayon ay nagbibigay lang tayo ng pangalan dito.
Narito ang eksaktong parehong halimbawa
na nakita natin sandali lang ang nakalipas na nakasulat nang mas malinaw sa
pamamagitan ng tensor product.
Muli, mayroon tayong isang-anim na katumbas ng isang-apat na beses ng isang-tatlo, isang-labindalawa ay katumbas ng isang-apat
na beses ng isang-tatlo at iba pa.
Narito, sa pamamagitan ng paraan ay ilang
alternatibong paraan upang isulat ang tensor
product ng dalawang vector.
Kapag gumagamit tayo ng direct notation at nagsusulat tayo ng dalawang cat sa tabi-tabi
na ganito, nangangahulugan ito ng tensor product.
Kaya maaari mong isipin ang tensor product bilang isang uri ng default na paraan upang i-multiply ang dalawang column vector nang magkasama.
Hindi magiging makatuwiran
na isipin ang isang produkto ng mga column vector na ganito sa pamamagitan ng matrix multiplication dahil hindi gumagana nang tama ang mga dimensyon,
kaya talagang walang alalahanin
tungkol sa kalabuan dito.
Maaari rin nating isulat ang
tensor product na ganito sa loob ng isang cat at nangangahulugan ito
ng eksaktong parehong bagay.
Ito ang tensor product
ng dalawang vector.
Ang una ay napaka-karaniwan at sa katunayan mas karaniwan ang isulat ang tensor product na ganito nang walang tensor product symbol
kaysa isama ang simbolo. Ang ikalawa ay
tiyak na mas hindi karaniwan, ngunit minsan ay napakatutulong lalo na
bilang isang paraan upang maalis ang pangangailangan
para sa karagdagang mga panaklong sa ilang mga sitwasyon.
Maaari rin nating ipahayag
ang mga tensor product nang malinaw sa pamamagitan ng mga aktwal na hanay ng
mga numero gaya ng makikita mo dito,
kung kukunin natin ang tensor product ng dalawang column vector na ito dito, ito ang vector na makukuha natin
at makikita mo na ang mga entry dito ay mga produkto ng mga entry
na nagmumula sa dalawang vector na ito.
Ang pag-order ng mga entry
ng tensor product ay pare-pareho sa
kahulugan mula sandali lang ang nakalipas sa kondisyon na sinusunod natin ang kombensyon
na inilarawan ko kanina para sa pag-order ng mga elemento
ng mga Cartesian product set.
Ang pagsunod sa kombensyong iyon ay katumbas ng pag-iisip
na ang mga index ng unang vector ay may
mas mataas na kahalagahan kaysa sa mga index ng ikalawang vector,
kaya makikita mo habang
pinagdadaanan natin ang mga entry ng tensor product, mayroon tayong lahat ng mga produkto na kinasasangkutan ng unang entry ng
unang vector sa kaliwa,
na siyang alpha isa. Pagkatapos ay lahat ng mga produkto
na kinasasangkutan ng ikalawang entry ng vector sa kaliwa,
na siyang alpha dalawa at iba pa.
Narito ang isang halimbawa kung saan
ang vector sa kaliwa ay may tatlong entry at ang vector sa
kanan ay may apat na entry upang mas malinaw nating makita kung ano ang nangyayari.
Mayroon tayong tatlong entry sa unang vector, kaya nagsisimula tayong isulat ang tatlong kopya ng ikalawang vector at pagkatapos ay ini-multiply natin ang bawat isa sa mga kopyang iyon
ng katumbas na entry
sa unang vector na ganito.
Dinadala natin ang mga alpha sa loob na ganito, at dito ay nag-mu-multiply lang tayo
ng mga vector ng mga scalar
at sa wakas ay inaalis natin ang
mga panaklong mula sa mga kopya at bumubuo tayo ng isang solong column
vector gaya ng makikita mo dito.
Bilang isang mahalagang paalala pansinin na mayroon tayong mga sumusunod na formula para sa tensor product ng
mga standard basis vector.
Kung kukunin natin ang tensor
product ng cat a at cat b, na maaari nating isulat gamit
ang tensor product symbol o wala, gaya ng makikita mo dito,
ang resulta ay simpleng cat ab.
Kung gusto nating isulat ang ab bilang ordered pair sa halip na isang string, magagawa natin iyon at makukuha natin
ang ekspresyong ito dito,
ngunit mas karaniwan
na isulat ito dito kung saan inaalis natin ang panaklong
ngunit inilalagay ang kuwit.
Mayroong kahulugan kung saan
ang isang ito na may panaklong ay mas tama, ngunit ito ay isang medyo karaniwang
kombensyon sa matematika
na ang mga panaklong ay inaalis kapag hindi sila kinakailangan o kapaki-pakinabang.
Maaari mong isipin ang mga ito bilang implicit sa isang ito dito at mas hindi makalat
at mas maganda ang tumingin dito.
Ang tensor product ay may
isang mahalagang katangian na ito ay bilinear at ang ibig sabihin nito ay ito ay linear
sa bawat isa sa dalawang argumento sa kondisyon na ang isa ay naayos.
Sa higit pang detalye ito ay
linear sa unang argumento na ipinahayag ng dalawang ekwasyong makikita mo dito,
ang una ay nagsasabing
kung magdagdag tayo ng dalawang vector na Phi1 at Phi2 at pagkatapos ay kumuha ng
tensor product kasama ang Psi, makukuha natin ang parehong resulta kung
kumuha tayo ng tensor product
kasama ang Psi una at pagkatapos ay magdagdag tayo.
Ang ikalawa ay nagsasabing kung
ini-multiply natin ang ilang vector na Phi ng ilang scalar na alpha at pagkatapos ay kumuha tayo ng
tensor product kasama ang Psi,
ang resulta ay kapareho ng kung una tayong kumuha ng tensor product ng Phi at Psi at pagkatapos ay ini-multiply natin ang resulta ng alpha.
At mayroon din tayong linearidad
sa ikalawang argumento na kapareho maliban na ang mga papel ng dalawang argumento ay napalitan.
Ang katangiang bilinear na ito
ay medyo madaling patunayan mula sa kahulugan, ngunit mabuti itong isulat na ganito dahil madalas nating
gagamitin ang mga formulang ito.
Pansinin sa pamamagitan ng paraan na ang mga scalar ay malayang dumadaloy sa pamamagitan ng mga tensor product sa kahulugang ipinahayag ng mga
pagkakapantay-pantay na makikita mo dito.
Iyon ay walang pagkakaiba
sa pagitan ng pag-multiply ng unang argumento ng isang
scalar na alpha sa kasong ito pag-multiply ng ikalawang
argumento ng scalar na iyon
o pag-multiply ng buong
bagay ng scalar na iyon.
Ang mga pagkakapantay-pantay na ito ay sumusunod mula sa
dalawang ekwasyong ito dito at dahil walang
pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng mga vector na ito, maaari tayong isulat lang ang
ekspresyon gaya ng makikita mo dito
nang walang mga panaklong dahil
walang pangangailangan para sa kanila.
Hindi sila nagdadagdag ng kahit anong kalinawan
o inaalis ang kahit anong kalabuan, kaya inaalis lang natin ang mga ito at
nakakakuha tayo ng mas malinis na ekspresyon.
Lahat ng ito ay napangkalahatang
sa tatlo o higit pang mga sistema.
Maaari nating tukuyin ang tensor product
ng tatlo o higit pang mga vector sa pamamagitan ng pangkalahatang-ideya ng formula
para sa tensor product ng dalawang vector sa natural na paraan,
na maaari mong makita na ipinahayag dito. Ang bawat entry ng tensor product ay ibinibigay ng produkto ng
mga katumbas na entry
ng mga vector na
kinukuha natin ang tensor product nito.
Isang katumbas na paraan upang
tukuyin ang tensor product ng tatlo o higit pang mga vector
ay gawin ito nang recursive na sa huli ay bumabalik sa kahulugan
ng tensor product sa pagitan ng dalawang vector. Kaya kung ang n ay hindi bababa sa tatlo, maaari nating isipin ang
tensor product ng n na mga vector
na Phi1 hanggang Phi n bilang tensor product sa pagitan ng anumang vector na makukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng
pagkuha ng tensor product ng unang n minus isa sa
kanila kasama ang huling vector,
at kung gusto mong malaman
kung ano ang tensor product ng unang n minus isa na mga vector, inilalapat mo ang formula
muli sa kaso n minus isa
ay hindi bababa sa tatlo o ginagamit ang kahulugan
mula dati kung ang n minus isa ay katumbas ng dalawa.
Ang dalawang paraan ng pag-iisip
tungkol sa mga tensor product ng tatlo o higit pang mga vector ay katumbas.
Sa pagkakataong ito kapag mayroon tayong
tatlo o higit pang mga vector na kinukuha natin ang tensor product nito, hindi tayo gumagamit ng termino na bilinear,
sa halip ginagamit natin ang termino multilinear,
ngunit ang ideya ay pareho.
Ang tensor product ay linear
sa bawat isa sa mga posisyon sa kondisyon na ang mga vector sa
lahat ng iba pang posisyon
ay naayos. Pagpapatuloy sa mga measurement
ng maraming sistema sa mga probabilistic state,
agad tayong nakakakuha ng isang pagtutukoy para sa kung paano gumagana ang mga measurement
para sa maraming sistema sa pamamagitan ng simpleng pag-iisip tungkol sa kanila
nang kolektibo bilang mga solong sistema
sa kondisyon na lahat ng
mga sistema ay sinusukat.
Bilang isang simpleng halimbawa, ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong dalawang
bit na X at Y at nang kolektibo sila ay nasa probabilistic
state na ito dito,
na nakita natin kanina. Natural, kung susukatin natin
ang parehong mga bit na ito, makukuha natin ang kinalabasan na 00
ibig sabihin ay zero para sa unang measurement at zero para sa ikalawang measurement na may probabilidad na isang kalahati at makukuha natin ang kinalabasan na 1,1
na may probabilidad na isang kalahati rin. Iyon ay medyo malinaw.
Sa esensya, ang pagsukat sa lahat ng sistema ay katumbas ng pagsukat
sa buong compound system.
Kung hindi natin susukat ang lahat
ng mga sistema gayunpaman, kundi sa halip ay susukat lang natin
ang ilan sa mga sistema, hindi
gaanong agad na malinaw ang sitwasyon
na binibigyan ng pansin muli ang kaso ng dalawang
sistema lamang upang makita ang esensya ng kung ano ang nangyayari sa
pinakamagimpleng setting nakakaramdam.
Maaari tayong magtanong ng sumusunod na tanong, ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong dalawang sistema, X at Y na magkasama bilang isang pares
sa ilang partikular na probabilistic state.
Ano ang mangyayari kung susukat lang tayo
ng X at wala tayong gagawin sa Y?
Maaari nating sagutin ang tanong na ito gamit ang ilang pangunahing teorya ng probabilidad.
Una, alam natin na ang probabilidad na ang measurement
ay nagbibigay ng isang partikular na kinalabasan ay dapat ibinibigay ng formulang ito
na makikita mo dito.
Maaari nating isipin ang mga probabilidad para sa bawat isa sa mga classical
state ng pares na XY na parang sinukat natin ang parehong at idinagdag natin ang lahat ng mga probabilidad
na pare-pareho sa X na nasa anumang classical state
na a na interesado tayo.
Kaya iyon ang dahilan kung bakit ang kabuuan dito ay para lamang sa mga classical state na b ng Y.
Isang paraan upang isipin ang
formulang ito ay ang probabilidad ng pagkita ng isang partikular na classical
state ng X kung susukat tayo nito
ay dapat pare-pareho sa probabilidad ng pagkita ng estado na iyon kung
sinukat din natin ang Y, kahit hindi natin sinukat,
iyon ay napaka-natural at intuitive. Ang probabilidad para sa isang measurement ng X na magbunga ng isang partikular na kinalabasan ay posibleng depende sa kung sinukat o hindi ang Y
ay sinukat din
anuman ang kinalabasan.
Kaya iyon ang nagsasabi sa atin kung ano
ang mga probabilidad para sa iba't ibang posibleng
kinalabasan ng measurement, ngunit ano ang nangyayari sa Y o sa ating
kaalaman ng Y bilang resulta?
Ang sagot ay maaaring mayroon pa ring
ilang kawalan ng katiyakan tungkol sa estado ng Y bilang isang
resulta ng pagkakaroon ng sinukat na X
at pagkita ng isang partikular na resulta. At ang kawalan ng katiyakan na iyon ay kinakatawan ng formulang ito dito para sa conditional probability
na ang Y ay nasa ilang partikular
na classical state na b, dahil ang X ay nasa ilang classical state,
anumang classical state a,
na nangyari nating nasukat.
Upang maging tiyak, ang probabilidad na ang Y ay
nasa ilang classical state na b, dahil ang X ay nasa classical state na a,
ay katumbas ng probabilidad
na ang X ay nasa a at ang Y ay nasa b na hinati sa probabilidad na ang X
ay nasa classical state na a.
Kaya kung susukat tayo ng X, makikita natin
ang iba't ibang classical state na may mga probabilidad na tinutukoy
ng formulang ito dito
at depende sa kung anong kinalabasan ang makukuha natin, maaari pa ring mayroon tayong ilang kawalan ng katiyakan tungkol sa classical state ng Y at
ang kawalan ng katiyakan na iyon ay naiisip
ng formulang ito dito.
Mayroong talagang isang napaka-madaling
paraan upang muling ipaliwanag ang lahat ng ito at upang magsagawa ng mga kalkulasyon
para sa mga partikular na kaso gamit ang direct notation
at ito ang ginagawa nito.
Nagsisimula tayo sa pagsulat ng
probabilistic state ng XY bilang isang vector na ganito, at
ito ay ganap na pangkalahatan.
Ang mga entry ay tinutukoy ng Pab at ang mga ito ay maaaring maging anumang mga numero basta ang buong vector
ay isang probability vector.
Maaari nating ipahayag ang cat ab bilang isang
tensor product gaya ng makikita mo dito at pagkatapos ay maaari nating gamitin ang
bilinearity ng tensor product
at partikular ang katotohanan na ito ay linear sa ikalawang argumento upang ipahayag ang vector na ito
gaya ng makikita mo dito.
Ang ginagawa natin ay epektibong inihihiwalay ang mga standard basis vector
sa kaliwang bahagi at inilalagay ang anumang kailangan natin
sa kanang bahagi
upang payagan iyon dahil iyon ang magpapakita kung ano ang mangyayari kapag
sinukat natin ang unang sistema na X.
Partikular ang probabilidad
na makakuha ng isang partikular na kinalabasan na a ay ang kabuuan sa lahat ng mga probabilidad na lumalabas sa
panaklong sa tabi ng cat a.
At sa kondisyon na nakakakuha ng
isang partikular na kinalabasan na a, ang probability vector na naglalarawan sa anumang kawalan ng katiyakan na nananatili tungkol sa Y
ay ang vector na nasa
mga panaklong sa tabi ng a.
Maliban na kailangan nating i-normalize ito upang gawing probability vector at iyon ay sinasabi na
kailangan nating hatiin ang vector na iyon
ng kabuuan ng mga entry sa vector na iyon upang bumuo ng isang probability vector.
Dito sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ang kabuuan ay kinukuha sa lahat ng
c sa gamma sa halip ng b para lamang gumamit ng ibang pangalan ng variable upang walang kalituhan
tungkol sa saklaw ng mga
variable kung baga.
Ang mga kabuuan sa numerator
at denominator ay dapat ituring na magkahiwalay na mga bagay at maaari nating maiwasan ang anumang pagkakataon
ng kalituhan tungkol doon
sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng iba't ibang
variable para sa dalawang kabuuan.
Narito ang isang mabilis na halimbawa upang
ilarawan kung paano gumagana ang lahat ng ito.
Ipagpalagay na ang XY ay isang pares ng mga bit sa probabilistic state na ito dito upang maunawaan kung ano ang nangyayari
kapag sinukat natin ang unang bit
at wala tayong ginagawa sa ikalawa, isinusulat natin ang vector gaya ng makikita mo dito kung saan ang cat zero at cat
isa sa unang posisyon
ay inihiwalay tulad ng
inilarawan natin sandali lang ang nakalipas.
Ang unang posibilidad ay
ang measurement outcome ay zero at ang probabilidad
ng pagkakataong iyon ay ang kabuuan ng mga probabilidad
sa loob ng mga panaklong
na naka-tensor sa cat zero. Kaya makukuha natin ang isang-labindalawa kasama ang isang-apat, na isang-tatlo at
sa kondisyon na ang kinalabasan ay zero.
Ang probabilistic state ng Y
ay nagiging vector na ito na na-normalize o katumbas na hinati ng probabilidad
na kababalikiran nating kalkulahin, at kaya ang makukuha natin ay
vector na ito dito.
Ang ikalawang posibilidad ay ang measurement outcome ay isa at ang kalkulasyon ay
ginagawa sa katulad na paraan gamit ang ikalawang termino sa ekspresyon
sa halip ng unang termino. At kung gusto mong i-verify ang mga detalye, sige gaya ng palagi at i-pause ang video upang bigyan ang iyong sarili ng sandali na gawin iyon.
Maaari kang magsagawa ng parehong
uri ng mga kalkulasyon upang malaman kung ano ang nangyayari kapag
ang Y ay sinukat sa halip na ang X.
Ito ang parehong paraan hanggang sa isang simetriya sa pagitan ng dalawang sistema.
Sa pagkakataong ito isinusulat natin ang
probability vector na ganito, na inihihiwalay ang mga standard basis vector sa kanan gaya ng makikita mo dito,
ngunit kung hindi man ay gumagana ito
sa eksaktong parehong paraan.
Maaari mo ring gamitin ang pamamaraang ito
para sa higit sa dalawang sistema.
Maaari itong maging medyo
makalat lamang upang isulat ang lahat ng kinakailangang mga ekspresyon, ngunit sa konsepto ito ay
eksaktong parehong ideya.
Sa wakas, para sa bahagi ng aralin
tungkol sa classical information, titingnan natin ang mga operasyon
sa mga probabilistic state
ng maraming sistema. Sumusunod sa parehong pangangatwiran na nakita na natin ng ilang beses.
Nagtatapos tayo na ang mga probabilistic na operasyon sa maraming sistema ay tulad din
ng mga probabilistic na operasyon sa mga solong sistema na kinakatawan
ng mga stochastic matrice.
Ngunit sa pagkakataong ito ang mga matrice na iyon
ay may mga hilera at hanay na katumbas ng Cartesian product ng mga indibidwal na sistema,
mga classical state set.
Iyon ay simpleng
tinitingnan natin ang isang compound system na parang ito ay isang solong sistema at bumabalik sa paglalarawan para sa kung paano gumagana ang mga probabilistic na operasyon
para sa mga solong sistema mula sa
nakaraang aralin.
Narito ang isang halimbawa ng isang operasyon na tinatawag na controlled-NOT
na operasyon sa dalawang bit na X at Y.
Ito ay talagang isang deterministic na operasyon at ang paraan ng pagtatrabaho nito ay
kung ang X ay katumbas ng isa, isang NOT na operasyon ay isinasagawa sa Y
at kung hindi ay kung ang X ay katumbas
ng zero wala ng mangyayari.
Minsan tinatawag ang bit na X
na control bit dahil tinutukoy nito kung
ang NOT na operasyon ay ilalapat sa Y o hindi
at ang Y ay tinatawag na target bit dahil ito ang bit na inaaksyunan ng NOT na operasyon.
Maaari mo ring isipin
ang pagpapalit ng mga papel ng X at Y upang ang Y ay maging control
bit at ang X ang target, ngunit iyon ay ibang operasyon
mula sa inilarawan dito dahil ang operasyon ay hindi
simetrikal sa pagitan ng X at Y.
Parehong tinatawag silang
mga controlled-NOT na operasyon, at kailangan lang nating tukuyin
kung alin sa mga bit ang control bit at
kung alin ang target bit.
Ang operasyong ito ay may aksyon
na makikita mo dito sa mga standard basis state at maaari mong suriin ang
aksyon na iyon laban sa kahulugan
ng operasyon. At narito ang matrix
na representasyon ng operasyon.
Kapag iniisip natin ang operasyong ito, naisip natin na mayroon
itong dalawang magkahiwalay na bit at gumaganap sila ng mga papel na inilarawan ko na
na ang X ang control bit
at ang Y ang target bit, ngunit talagang wala
tungkol sa aksyon dito o sa matrix na representasyong ito
na nangangailangan na
isipin natin ang dalawang bit na ito bilang magkahiwalay na mga bit.
Maaari nating alternatibong
isipin ang operasyong ito bilang isang deterministic
na operasyon sa isang sistema na may apat na classical state
na napagpasyahan nating pangalanan
ang 0,0, 0,1, 1,0 at 1,1.
Narito ang isa pang halimbawa ng
isang probabilistic na operasyon sa dalawang bit, na hindi isang deterministic
na operasyon sa pagkakataong ito.
Ang operasyon ay nagtatakda ng Y na katumbas ng X na may probabilidad na isang kalahati at kung hindi ay pumupunta ito sa kabila at nagtatakda ng X na katumbas ng Y.
Ang operasyong ito ay walang espesyal na pangalan ito ay para lamang bilang isang halimbawa.
At narito ang matrix
na representasyon ng operasyong ito.
Makikita mo na maaari itong ipahayag bilang isang average ng dalawang matrice, isa na kumakatawan sa deterministic na operasyon
kung saan ang Y ay itinatakda sa anumang
halaga na nakaimbak sa X at ang isa pa na nagtatakda
ng X na katumbas ng Y.
Kaya dito makikita natin na maaari tayong kumuha ng mga average ng mga stochastic matrice upang makakuha ng mga bago tulad ng sa nakaraang aralin.
Ngayon, pag-isipan natin
ang sumusunod na tanong. Ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong dalawang
probabilistic na operasyon bawat isa sa sarili nitong sistema
na inilalarawan gaya ng karaniwang ginagawa ng mga stochastic
matrice at upang maging tiyak, ipagpalagay na ang M ay
isang probabilistic na operasyon
sa isang sistema X at ang N ay isang
probabilistic na operasyon sa isang sistema Y.
Ang tanong ay kung
sabay nating isinasagawa ang M sa X at ang N sa Y, paano natin inilalarawan
ang epekto nito
sa compound system na XY?
Pag-iisip tungkol dito
nang sandali nang intuitive, kung sabay nating
isinasagawa ang dalawang operasyon sa kani-kanilang mga sistema,
talagang isinasagawa tayo ng isang
operasyon sa compound system, kaya dapat itong ilarawan
ng ilang stochastic matrix.
Ang maikling sagot sa
tanong na ito ay ang matrix ay nakukuha sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng tensor product, hindi sa pagitan ng mga vector tulad
ng tinalakay natin kanina,
kundi sa pagitan ng mga matrice sa
kasong ito, ang mga matrice na M at N.
Kaya maglaan tayo ng ilang sandali
upang talakayin ang mga tensor product ng mga matrice at pagkatapos ay babalik tayo sa tanong na ito.
Narito ang kahulugan
ng tensor product sa pagitan ng mga matrice at
ito ay lubos na katulad ng tensor product sa pagitan ng mga vector.
Kung ipagpalagay natin na ang dalawang
matrice na ginagawa natin ay nakasulat sa mga form na makikita mo dito upang ang mga entry ng M ay
tinutukoy ng alpha ab bilang a at b
sumasaklaw sa ilang classical state set na sigma at ang mga entry ng N ay
tinutukoy ng beta cd bilang c at d
sumasaklaw sa ilang classical state set na gamma.
Pagkatapos ang produkto ng M at N ay ang matrix na makikita mo dito.
Mayroon tayong katulad
sa tensor product sa pagitan ng mga vector.
Ang mga hilera at hanay ng M tensor N ay katumbas ng mga pares ng mga classical state na nakasulat bilang mga string dito,
at ang mga entry ay mga produkto ng mga katumbas na entry ng M at N.
Narito ang isa pang paraan upang isulat ito sa pamamagitan ng mga indibidwal
na entry ng mga matrice na ito.
Ang ac bd entry ng M tensor N ay ang produkto ng ab entry
ng M at ng cd entry ng N.
Mayroong isa pang paraan ng
paglalarawan ng M tensor N, na ito ang
natatanging matrix na nagbabago ng anumang vector ng form na Phi tensor Psi
sa tensor product ng M na inilapat sa Phi kasama ang N na inilapat sa Psi, at ito ay dapat totoo para sa bawat pagpili
ng mga vector na Phi at Psi.
Isang paraan upang isipin ito
ay ang tensor product ng mga matrice ay perpektong nakikiisa sa tensor product sa pagitan ng mga vector.
Ito ay isang ekwasyon na
natural mong inaasahang totoo at totoo nga ito.
Sa pamamagitan ng mga matrice na
nakasulat nang malinaw, maaari nating tukuyin ang tensor
product gaya ng makikita mo dito.
Maraming tuldok sa ekwasyong ito at nilayong
ilarawan ang pattern, na kapareho ng pattern
na nagkaroon tayo para sa mga vector maliban na ngayon ay mayroon tayong mga hilera at hanay
kumpara sa mga column vector lamang.
Kung hindi pa malinaw, ang
sumusunod na halimbawa ay maaaring makatulong.
Dito ay pinag-uusapan natin
ang tensor product ng dalawang dalawa sa dalawang matrice.
Una ay nagsusulat tayo ng apat
na kopya ng ikalawang matrice, isa para sa bawat entry ng unang matrice.
Ini-multiply natin ang bawat isa sa mga
kopyang ito ng ikalawang matrice ng katumbas
na entry ng unang matrice,
at pagkatapos ay kinokolekta natin ang lahat ito sa
isang solong apat sa apat na matrice gaya ng makikita mo dito.
Maaari rin nating tukuyin ang
tensor product ng tatlo o higit pang matrice sa katulad na paraan at marahil ang pinakamadaling
paraan upang ipahayag ito
ay gaya ng makikita mo dito
kung saan mayroon tayong formula para sa bawat entry ng tensor product, na simpleng produkto
ng mga katumbas na entry.
Maaari mo ring tukuyin ang tensor product ng tatlo o higit pang matrice nang recursive sa pamamagitan ng tensor
product ng dalawang matrice lamang tulad ng sa mga vector.
At isang huling paalala ay
ang tensor product ng mga matrice ay multiplicative, na nangangahulugang ang isang
produkto ng mga tensor product
ay katumbas ng tensor
product ng mga produkto.
Maaari mong isipin ito
bilang isang pangkalahatang-ideya ng formula mula sandali lang ang nakalipas para sa aksyon ng tensor
product ng mga matrice
sa tensor product ng mga vector. At muli, ito ay isang bagay na
tiyak na inaasahan nating totoo at maaari tayong matuwa na totoo ito
at gagamitin natin ang
katotohanang ito kapag kailangan natin.
At ngayon ay maaari tayong bumalik sa
tanong mula kanina na nagtatanong kung paano natin inilalarawan
ang epekto ng pagsasagawa ng isang operasyong M sa isang sistema X
at isang operasyong N sa sistema Y nang magkasama bilang isang operasyon
sa compound system na XY.
At ang sagot sa
tanong na iyon ay ang aksyon ay inilalarawan ng
tensor product ng M at N.
Ang mga tensor product ay kumakatawan ng kalayaan sa pagkakataong ito sa pagitan ng mga operasyon kumpara sa nakita
natin dati para sa mga probability vector.
Narito ang isang mabilis na halimbawa. Ipagpalagay na isinasagawa natin
ang probabilistic na operasyon na inilalarawan ng matrix na ito sa isang bit na X.
Ito ay isang operasyon
na nakita natin sa aralin isa at sabay na isinasagawa natin
ang isang NOT na operasyon sa isang bit na Y.
Ang pinagsanib na operasyon sa pares na XY ay samakatuwid ay kinakatawan ng tensor product ng mga matrice na katumbas ng dalawang operasyong ito.
Narito ang isa sa X at
narito ang NOT na operasyon sa Y at makukuha natin ang matrix na ito
na makikita mo dito.
At makikita mo na talagang
ito ay isang stochastic matrix at palagi itong magiging ganoon.
Ang tensor product ng anumang
dalawang stochastic matrice o anumang bilang ng mga stochastic
matrice para sa bagay na iyon ay palaging magiging stochastic.
Ito ay isang napaka-karaniwang sitwasyon
na ating natatagpuan sa isang sitwasyon kung saan ang isang operasyon ay
isinasagawa sa isang sistema at wala ng ginagawa sa isa pang sistema.
Sa sitwasyong ito, sinusunod natin ang eksaktong parehong reseta na may pag-unawa na ang paggawa ng wala ay kinakatawan ng identity matrix.
Halimbawa, kung mayroon tayong dalawang bit na X at
Y at iri-reset natin ang bit na X sa zero state, na kapareho ng bagay
ng pagsasagawa ng constant
zero function sa X at wala tayong ginagawa sa Y, ang resultang operasyon sa pares na XY
ay kinakatawan ng tensor product na ito dito.
Lahat ng ito ay napangkalahatang
sa anumang bilang ng mga sistema at makikita natin ang ilang karagdagang mga halimbawa kapag lumipat tayo sa quantum setting, na gumagana sa eksaktong parehong paraan
maliban na mayroon tayong mga unitary matrice sa halip ng mga stochastic matrice, at iyon ay sapat na tungkol sa
classical information sa ngayon.
Ngayon ay ibibigay natin ang ating pansin
sa quantum information at kung paano ito gumagana para sa maraming sistema.
Ang pattern ay pareho tulad ng
para sa classical information.
Maaari nating tingnan ang maraming quantum system bilang mga solong compound system at ilapat ang alam natin
mula sa nakaraang aralin.
Muli, ang mga tensor product
ay magiging pangunahing papel at sa kabuuan ay nakakakuha tayo ng paglalarawan para sa kung paano gumagana ang quantum information
para sa maraming sistema.
Iyon ay lubos na katulad
at matematikong katulad sa nakita natin para sa
classical information.
Magsisimula tayo sa mga quantum state.
Ang mga quantum state ng maraming sistema ay kinakatawan ng mga column vector na may mga entry na complex number
at Euclidean norm na katumbas ng isa
tulad ng mga quantum state
ng mga solong sistema.
Sa pagkakataong ito ang mga index ng
mga quantum state vector ay katumbas ng Cartesian product ng mga classical state set
ng mga indibidwal na sistema
dahil muli, iyon ang
classical state set ng compound system.
Halimbawa, kung ang X at Y ay mga qubit, ang classical state
set para sa pares na XY nang magkasama ay ang Cartesian product ng
binary alphabet sa sarili nito,
na maaari nating isipin bilang
set ng lahat ng binary string na may haba na dalawa.
Kaya ang mga vector na makikita mo dito ay lahat halimbawa ng mga quantum
state vector ng XY.
Kung gusto natin, maaari nating alternatibong isulat
ang mga vector na ito na ganito kung saan mayroon tayong hiwalay na
cat para sa bawat qubit
kung saan ang tensor product
sa pagitan nila ay implicit.
O maaari rin nating isulat ang
tensor product symbol nang malinaw na ganito kung mas gusto mo.
At isa pang opsyon ay
ang lagyan ng subscript ang mga cat ng mga pangalan ng mga sistema
na kinakatawan nila na ganito.
At maaari mong gawin ito gamit
ang tensor product symbol o wala.
Minsan iyon ay napakatutulong para sa pagpapanatiling malinaw ng mga bagay.
Ito ay mga iba't ibang estilo para sa pagpapahayag ng parehong mga vector at maaari tayong pumili kung alin ang gusto natin o kung alin ang mas gusto natin o
kung alin ang pinaka-makatuwiran
para sa sitwasyong nasa kamay. Kapag mas nagiging kumplikado ang mga bagay halimbawa, maaari nating mapagpasyahan na ang isa sa
mga estilo na ito ay nagdadagdag ng kalinawan
at malaya tayong pumili
kung alin ang gusto natin.
Ang mga tensor product ng mga quantum state vector ay quantum state vector din.
Para sa kaso ng dalawang sistema halimbawa, kung ang Phi ay isang quantum state
vector ng isang sistema X at ang Psi ay isang quantum state
vector ng isang sistema Y,
ang tensor product ng Phi at Psi ay isang quantum state vector ng XY.
Tinatawag natin ang mga estado na ganito na mga product state at katulad ng nakita natin sa classical probabilistic setting, kinakatawan nila ang kalayaan
sa pagitan ng mga sistema X at Y.
Kaya halimbawa, kung ang isang tao ay may laboratoryo
sa isang bahagi ng mundo at lumikha sila ng sistema X at ini-initialize ito sa quantum state na Phi
at ang isa pang tao sa
isa pang bahagi ng mundo ay nag-iindependyenteng nag-iinisyalize ng isang sistema Y sa quantum state na Psi,
pagkatapos ay kung pipiliin nating isipin ang XY bilang bumubuo ng isang solong sistema kahit na ito ay dalawang bahagi o sa iba't ibang bahagi ng mundo,
ang compound system na XY ay
nasa estado na Phi tensor Psi.
Lahat ng ito ay napangkalahatang sa
higit sa dalawang sistema sa natural na paraan.
Kung mayroon tayong mga quantum
state na Psi1 hanggang PsiN ng mga hiwalay na sistema na Xn hanggang Xn, ang tensor product ng n na mga vector na ito
ay kumakatawan ng isang quantum state, na muli ay tinatawag na product state ng compound system na X1 hanggang Xn.
Narito ang isang halimbawa ng isang
quantum state ng dalawang qubit.
Kahit na hindi ito agad
mukhang ganoon. Ito ay isang halimbawa ng isang product state dahil maaari nating isulat
ito bilang isang tensor product gaya ng makikita mo dito.
Kaya ito ay isang halimbawa ng isang
product state anuman ang paraan ng pagsulat nito, ang may kaugnayan ay kung
posible itong isulat bilang isang tensor product.
Ang quantum state na ito, gayunpaman, na muli ay isang estado ng dalawang
qubit ay hindi isang product state.
Ito ay katulad sa diwa sa
halimbawa na nakita natin sa probabilistic setting ng dalawang perpektong correlated na random bit
at ipinapakita ng parehong argumento na hindi ito maaaring isulat
bilang isang tensor product.
Kaya ilipat natin ito dito at tingnan natin ang argumento nang may kaunting higit na detalye.
Isipin natin na
maaari nating isulat ang estado na ito bilang isang tensor product ng
dalawang vector na Phi at Psi.
Ang entry na katumbas
ng classical state na 0,1 ay zero para sa vector na ito, na maaari nating makita sa pamamagitan ng pagtingin dito.
Gayunpaman, ito ay magpapahiwatig, kung ang vector ay isang tensor
product ng dalawang vector, na ang zero entry ng Phi
na beses ng one entry ng Psi
ay katumbas ng zero, ngunit nangangahulugan iyon na alinman
ang zero entry ng Phi o ang one entry ng Psi ay katumbas ng zero
o pareho silang maaaring katumbas ng zero, ngunit iyon ay sumasalungat sa katotohanan
na ang dalawang produktong ito dito ay parehong dapat na hindi-zero.
Sila ay katumbas ng isa
sa aming squared ng dalawa. Ang argumento ay talagang halos
kapareho ng sa probabilistic setting.
Walang natatangi
na quantum tungkol dito.
Kahit paano, ang natutuklasan natin ay ang orihinal na estado ay hindi isang product state.
Pansinin na hindi mahalaga
na ang dalawang numerong ito dito ay isa sa squared ng dalawa.
Ang mahalaga lang ay ang
parehong halaga ay hindi-zero.
Ang partikular na quantum state na ito
ay isang napaka-interesanteng isa. Ito ay isang halimbawa ng isang
entangled state ng dalawang qubit.
Pag-uusapan pa natin
ang entanglement sa ibang pagkakataon sa serye.
Ang entanglement ay maaaring kumplikado, partikular kapag
pinag-uusapan natin ang mga quantum state sa pangkalahatang formulasyon
ng quantum information,
ngunit dito sa pinasimpleng paglalarawan ng quantum information ang entanglement ay katumbas ng kawalan ng kalayaan.
Kaya para sa isang quantum state vector,
kung hindi ito isang product state, ito ay isang entangled state
at ang partikular na estado na ito
ay karaniwang itinuturing bilang
ang archetypical na halimbawa ng isang entangled quantum state.
At sa katunayan, minsan
iniisip natin ang estado na ito bilang kumakatawan sa isang unit ng entanglement, partikular kapag iniisip natin ang entanglement
bilang isang resource na maaaring
gamitin upang gumawa ng mga kagiliw-giliw na bagay.
Ang quantum state na
talakayin natin kamakailan ay isa sa apat na tinatawag na Bell state, na makikita mo dito
kasama ang mga pangalan
na karaniwang ginagamit para sa mga estadong ito, Phi plus, Phi minus,
Psi plus at Psi minus.
Lahat sila ay entangled
at bumubuo sila ng isang basis para sa espasyo ng lahat ng
mga vector na kumakatawan ng mga estado ng dalawang qubit.
Kaya ang apat na vector na ito nang magkasama
ay tinatawag na Bell basis.
Ito ay isang napaka-karaniwang
natutagpuang koleksyon ng mga quantum state na pinangalanan
bilang karangalan ni John Bell, na isang pisiko na gumawa ng
napaka-mahalagang kontribusyon
sa pag-aaral ng entanglement noong 1960s.
Narito ang ilang kilalang halimbawa ng mga quantum state ng tatlong qubit.
Ang una ay tinatawag na GHZ state.
Ito ay medyo katulad ng Phi
plus state na nakita natin kanina maliban para sa tatlong qubit sa halip na dalawa.
At ang ikalawang halimbawa ay tinatawag na W state at mukhang ganito gaya ng makikita mo dito, kaya ito ay uniform sa lahat ng
tatlong binary string
na may haba na tatlo na may
eksaktong isang bit na nakatakda sa isa.
Wala sa mga estadong ito ang isang product state at parehong may mga kagiliw-giliw na katangian at lumitaw nang medyo karaniwan bilang mga halimbawa, kaya mabuting malaman ang mga ito
at makikita natin sila muli.
Susunod ay pag-uusapan natin ang
mga measurement ng mga sistema sa mga quantum state.
Sumusunod sa parehong pangangatwiran
na sinusunod natin hanggang ngayon sa aralin, na isipin ang maraming sistema
na parang sila ay mga solong sistema. Agad tayong dumarating sa isang paglalarawan para sa kung paano gumagana ang mga measurement ng
maraming quantum system
sa kondisyon na lahat ng
mga sistema ay sinusukat.
Iyon ay kung mayroon tayong ilang
quantum state vector na Psi na kumakatawan ng isang quantum
state ng isang n-tuple na mga sistema
na X1 hanggang Xn at sinusukat natin
ang buong compound system, na katumbas ng pagsukat
ng bawat isa sa mga indibidwal na sistema, pagkatapos ay ang bawat posibleng n-tuple
ng mga classical state ay magiging kinalabasan ng measurement
na may probabilidad na katumbas ng
absolute value squared ng entry ng Psi na
katumbas ng n-tuple na iyon.
Halimbawa, kung mayroon tayong
isang pares ng mga sistema na XY sa quantum state na ito dito, pagkatapos ay kung susukat natin ang parehong sistema,
makukuha natin ang kinalabasan na zero puso ibig sabihin ay zero para sa measurement ng X at puso para sa measurement ng Y
na may probabilidad na siyam na dalawampu't lima at makukuha natin ang kinalabasan na isa
ispada na may probabilidad na 16/25.
Iyon ay talagang medyo malinaw. Karaniwang binabalewala natin ang katotohanan na ito ay dalawang magkahiwalay na sistema at tinitingnan natin ang mga ito na parang
sila ay isang solong sistema,
ngunit ito ay nagtatanong ng
sumusunod na natural na tanong, na tinalakay na natin
sa classical setting.
Ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong dalawang sistema na X at Y na kolektibong
nasa ilang quantum state at hindi natin susukat ang parehong, kundi
susukat lang natin ang isang sistema.
Sabihin nating susukat natin ang sistema X at wala tayong gagawin sa Y.
Siyempre, maaari rin nating itanong kung ano ang nangyayari kung susukat natin ang Y at hindi
ang X at mas pangkalahatan kung mayroon tayong
tatlo o higit pang mga sistema
at susukat tayo ng ilang tamang subset nito. Ngunit kapag mayroon na tayong
sagot sa tanong na ito, magkakaroon din tayo ng mga sagot sa
mga tanong na iyon.
Alam natin na sa pangkalahatan
ang isang quantum state vector ng pares na XY ay kumukuha ng
form na makikita mo dito, ipagpalagay na gaya ng karaniwang ginagawa na ang sigma at gamma
ay ang mga classical state set
ng X at Y ayon sa pagkakasunud-sunod.
Ang mga entry ng vector na ito ay
tinutukoy ng alpha ab na sumasaklaw sa lahat ng posibleng pagpili ng a at b,
at maaari silang maging anumang complex number na nagdudulot sa vector na ito
na maging isang unit vector.
Alam na natin na kung
sinukat ang parehong sistema, nakukuha natin ang mga probabilidad para sa iba't ibang posibleng kinalabasan
sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng absolute value squared ng katumbas na entry.
At kaya kung ang X lamang ay sinukat, ang probabilidad na
makakuha ng isang partikular na kinalabasan na a ay ibinibigay ng ekspresyong ito,
simpleng idadagdag natin ang lahat ng
posibleng kinalabasan na b, na maaaring makuha
kung sinukat din ang Y kahit na hindi.
Ang ideya ay pareho tulad ng sa
probabilistic setting.
Ang probabilidad na makakuha ng
isang partikular na kinalabasan kapag sinukat ang X ay hindi
maaaring depende sa kung sinukat din ang Y o hindi.
Kaya iyon ang nagsasabi sa atin kung ano
ang mga probabilidad para sa iba't ibang posibleng kinalabasan.
Bukod dito, magkakaroon ng ilang
pagbabago sa estado ng Y bilang resulta ng pagsasagawa ng measurement sa X at pagkakuha ng isang partikular na kinalabasan.
Kaya tingnan natin kung paano ito gumagana.
Katulad ng ginawa natin sa
probabilistic setting, maaari nating ipahayag ang
quantum state vector na Psi gaya ng makikita mo dito
kung saan ang Phi a ay vector na ito para sa bawat pagpili ng classical state na a ng sistema X,
ginagamit natin ang bilinearity
ng tensor product tulad ng dati.
Ngayon ay pinili nating pangalanan
ang mga iba't ibang vector na ito na Phi a, para lamang sa kaginhawahan.
Naobserbahan na natin na ang probabilidad na ang measurement ay nagbubunga ng
bawat posibleng kinalabasan na a ay gaya ng makikita mo dito,
ngunit ngayon ay makikita natin na ang probabilidad na ito ay katumbas ng Euclidean norm
squared ng vector na Phi a,
at ngayon bilang resulta ng measurement ng X na nagbibigay ng isang partikular na kinalabasan na a, mayroon tayong quantum state
ng compound system na XY
na nagiging estado na ito
na makikita mo dito.
Tulad ng sa mga solong sistema, ang estado ay nag-co-collapse sa esensya, ngunit hindi ito ganap na nag-co-collapse sa pangkalahatan,
nag-co-collapse lamang ito hangga't kailangan upang maging pare-pareho
sa measurement ng X na nagbubunga ng kinalabasan na a.
Ang quantum state ng Y ay nagiging Phi a na na-normalize ibig sabihin ay hahati tayo ng Euclidean norm nito
upang ito ay maging isang unit vector. Ito ay katulad sa nangyari sa
probabilistic setting kung saan sa halip ng paghahati
ng Euclidean norm,
hati tayo ng kabuuan
ng mga entry ng Phi a upang makakuha ng probability vector.
Ngunit dito dahil pinag-uusapan natin
ang mga quantum state, hati tayo ng Euclidean norm
upang makakuha ng quantum state vector.
Tingnan natin ang ilang halimbawa upang makita kung paano ito gumagana
para sa isang partikular na estado.
Narito ang estado na aming isasaalang-alang. Ipinagpapalagay nating ang X at Y ay mga qubit at nasa partikular na estado na Psi ang mga ito.
At ipagpalagay na ang X ay sinukat.
Nagsisimula tayo sa pagsulat ng
mga estado ng Psi gaya ng makikita mo dito, na epektibong inihihiwalay ang
mga standard basis factor ng X
at ini-tensor ang mga ito sa anumang kailangan natin upang makuha ang orihinal na estado.
Tulad lang ng sa pangkalahatang
paglalarawan mula sandali lang ang nakalipas.
Ang probabilidad na makakuha ng kinalabasan na zero ay ang Euclidean norm squared
ng vector na ito dito.
Ang bagay na naka-tensor sa cat zero sa ating ekspresyon ng vector na Psi.
At kaya ang probabilidad ay tatlong-apat at sa kondisyon na
makukuha ang kinalabasan na zero.
Ang quantum state ng
pares na XY ay nagiging ito kung saan in-normalize natin ang
vector na naka-tensor sa cat zero,
at iyon ay katumbas ng
paghahati ng square root ng probabilidad na
kababalikiran nating kalkulahin.
Pagkatapos ay maaari nating pasimplehin
at ito ang makukuha natin.
Ang probabilidad na makuha ang
measurement outcome na isa ay kinakalkula sa katulad na paraan.
Kinukuha natin ang Euclidean norm squared
ng vector na ito dito. Ang bagay na naka-tensor sa cat
isa sa ating ekspresyon ng Psi
at ang resultang
probabilidad ay isang-apat, na kailangan nito siyempre, dahil ang ating mga probabilidad
ay dapat maging isang sa kabuuan.
Sa kasong ito, ang quantum state ng XY ay nagiging ito kung saan muli ay nino-normalize natin sa pamamagitan ng paghahati ng Euclidean norm
upang makuha natin ang quantum
state vector na ito bilang resulta.
Ang parehong paraan ay ginagamit
sa simetrikal na paraan, kung ang Y ay sinukat sa halip na ang X.
Narito ang orihinal na quantum state vector, at sa pagkakataong ito dahil ang Y
ay sinukat sa halip na ang X,
ipinapahayag natin ang vector na Psi
gaya ng makikita mo dito, kung saan sa pagkakataong ito inihihiwalay natin ang
mga standard basis vector ng Y
sa halip na ang X na ini-tensor
kasama ang anumang kailangan natin upang makakuha ng ekspresyon ng Psi.
Pinagdaraanan ang kalkulasyon, na maaari mong suriin sa pamamagitan ng
pag-pause ng video kung gusto mo.
Nakikita natin na ang probabilidad
na makakuha ng kinalabasan na zero ay Phi8 sa pagkakataong ito, at narito ang
quantum state vector
na nagresulta sa kondisyon
sa pagkakuha ng resultang iyon.
At ang probabilidad na makakuha ng
kinalabasan na isa ay tatlong-walo, kung saan ito ang
ating quantum state vector.
Maaari kang gumamit ng eksaktong parehong paraan sakali na mayroon kang higit sa dalawang sistema at anumang tamang subset
nito ay sinukat.
At mayroong isang halimbawa
sa nilalaman ng textbook para sa araling ito na maaari mong
tingnan kung interesado ka.
Sa madaling salita, lagi nating maaaring hatiin ang mga sistema sa dalawang magkahiwalay na koleksyon, ang mga sinusukat
at ang mga hindi.
At kapag nagawa na natin iyon, bumabalik tayo sa pamamaraan
na inilarawan ko kamakailan, at ganoon gumagana ang mga measurement para sa maraming quantum system.
At ngayon sa wakas, lumipat tayo sa mga unitary
na operasyon sa maraming sistema.
Gamit ang parehong pangunahing ideya na ang maraming sistema ay maaaring tingnan bilang mga solong compound system.
Nagtatapos tayo sa nakasulat
dito sa screen, ang mga quantum na operasyon sa mga compound system ay kinakatawan ng mga unitary matrice
tulad ng sa mga solong sistema at partikular ang mga hilera at hanay ng mga unitary matrice na iyon ay katumbas ng Cartesian product
ng mga classical state set ng anumang koleksyon ng
mga sistemang pinag-uusapan natin.
Halimbawa, kung mayroon tayong sistema X
na ang mga classical state ay isa, dalawa, at tatlo at ang Y ay isang qubit,
ang matrix na makikita mo dito ay isang halimbawa ng isang unitary matrix na kumakatawan ng isang
operasyon sa pares na XY.
Ang mga detalye ng kung paano
ino-order natin ang mga Cartesian product na tinalakay natin dati ay hindi talaga mahalaga para sa
kapakanan ng halimbawang ito, ito ay isang anim sa anim na matrice
na maging unitary.
Walang espesyal tungkol dito, kahit na ito ay binubuo ng ilang
mahahalagang matrice.
Ang punto ay maaari kang
pumili ng anumang anim sa anim na unitary matrice at ito ay kumakatawan ng
isang unitary na operasyon sa XY.
Kung maglalapat tayo ng isang koleksyon ng
mga unitary na operasyon nang nakapag-iisa bawat isa sa sarili nitong sistema, ang aksyon ng lahat ng mga ito nang magkasama
sa compound system ay
ibinibigay ng tensor product.
At dito sa screen maaari mong makita ang isang mas tiyak
na pahayag ng katotohanang iyon.
Kung ang ating mga unitary na operasyon ay inilalarawan ng mga unitary matrice na U1 hanggang Un isa para sa bawat isa sa ating mga sistema,
ang pinagsanib na aksyon
sa compound system ay ibinibigay ng tensor
product ng U1 hanggang Un.
Muli, katulad ng sa probabilistic setting, isang mahalagang halimbawa ay kung maglalapat tayo ng ilang unitary na operasyon
U sa isang sistema X at wala tayong
ginagawa sa ilang ibang sistema Y.
Ang operasyon sa XY na makukuha natin ay U na naka-tensor kasama ang identity matrix.
Ang identity matrix
ay naglalarawan ng paggawa ng wala sa Y.
Minsan kapaki-pakinabang ang malinaw na isulat na ang identity matrix na ito
ay katumbas ng sistema Y, para lamang gawing mas malinaw ang mga formula.
At isang opsyon ay ang
bigyan ng subscript ang identity matrix na ganito na nagpapahiwatig ng sistema na kinakakilos nito.
Kapag malinaw na, gayunpaman karaniwang hindi na tayo
nag-abala sa isang subscript, ngunit kapag mas nagiging kumplikado ang mga bagay, maaari itong maging napakatutulong.
At maaari rin nating isaalang-alang
ang simetrikal na kaso kung saan ang ilang unitary
na operasyon V ay inilalapat sa Y at walang ginagawa sa X,
at sa pagkakataong ito ang resultang
unitary na operasyon sa XY, ay kinakatawan ng tensor product na ito dito.
At muli, maaari nating lagyan ng subscript ang
identity matrix kung makakatulong ito.
Narito ang ilang partikular na mga halimbawa.
Kung ang X at Y ay mga qubit at
isinasagawa natin ang isang Hadamard na operasyon sa X at wala tayong ginagawa sa Y, makukuha natin ang matrix na makikita mo dito.
Kung sa kabilang banda, isinasagawa natin ang Hadamard na operasyon sa Y at wala tayong ginagawa sa X, ang pag-order ng tensor
product ay nababaligtad.
At kaya nakukuha natin ang matrix
na makikita mo dito.
Hindi bawat unitary na operasyon
sa isang compound system ay maaaring ipahayag bilang isang tensor product.
Kung mayroon tayong tensor product,
mayroon tayong kalayaan.
At mayroong ilang medyo
pangunahing mga halimbawa ng mga operasyon na tiyak
na hindi kumikilalang nakapag-iisa sa maraming sistema.
Halimbawa, kung ang X at Y ay may
parehong classical state set, na maaaring maging alinmang
classical state set na sigma,
maaari nating isipin ang
swap na operasyon sa pares na XY.
Ang operasyong ito ay hindi nagbabago ng pag-order ng dalawang sistema, nananatili pa rin ang X sa
kaliwa at ang Y sa kanan, kundi kumakatawan ito sa pagpapalit ng mga nilalaman
ng dalawang sistema. Dito makikita mo na ipinahayag
sa form ng isang ekwasyon kung saan mayroon tayong isang tensor
product ng dalawang quantum state.
Isa pang paraan upang isulat ito ay bilang
isang matrice gaya ng makikita natin dito.
Ang paraan ng pag-iisip
tungkol sa paglalarawang ito ay nagpapakita sa iyo kung ano ang nangyayari para sa mga standard basis vector.
At kapag alam na natin kung ano ang nangyayari
para sa mga standard basis vector, alam na natin kung ano ang nangyayari para sa
mga arbitrary na quantum state sa pamamagitan ng linearidad,
na talagang totoo rin para sa
ekspresyong ito dito.
Kaya ang partikular na operasyong ito dito ay isang deterministic na operasyon pati na rin isang unitary na operasyon.
Kung ang X at Y ay mga qubit, halimbawa, makukuha natin ang matrix
na representasyong ito dito.
Narito ang isang kagiliw-giliw na koneksyon
sa pagitan ng swap na operasyon at ng apat na Bell state, na ipinapakita dito para sa kaginhawahan.
Ang swap na operasyon ay nag-iiwan ng
tatlo sa kanila nang hindi nagbabago, ngunit naglalagay ng minus sign sa
harap ng Psi minus state,
kaya may espesyal
tungkol sa isang iyon.
Maaari mong suriin ang mga ekwasyong ito nang direkta sa pamamagitan ng pagtingin sa mga vector na ito at pagsasaalang-alang kung ano ang nangyayari
para sa mga standard basis state
ang pagpapalit ng dalawang classical state para sa unang tatlong Bell
state ay hindi gumagawa ng anumang bagay makukuha natin ang parehong estado na sinimulan natin.
Sa ikaapat na kaso gayunpaman, ang minus sign ay epektibong
gumagalaw mula sa isang termino patungo sa isa pa kapag isinasagawa natin ang swap ng mga classical state,
at iyon ay katumbas ng pag-multiply ng vector ng minus isa.
Kaya ang pagsasagawa ng swap na operasyon ay kahit papaano ay nagpapalabas ng minus sign
mula sa ikaapat na Bell state na ito.
Magkakaroon tayo ng higit na masasabi tungkol sa
mga ekwasyong ito sa ibang pagkakataon, ngunit ngayon ay lumipat tayo sa
isa pang uri ng operasyon, na siyang isang controlled na operasyon.
Ipagpapalagay natin na ang X ay isang qubit at ang Y ay alinmang sistema na gusto mo.
Kung ang U ay isang unitary na operasyon sa Y, ang isang controlled U na operasyon sa XY ay ang operasyong
ipinahayag dito.
Una, gamit ang direct notation at pagkatapos gamit ang tinatawag na block matrix isaisip mo lang ang pagpuno
sa mas malaking matrix na ito
ng mga mas maliliit na ito kung saan ang mga zero na ito ay talagang kumakatawan ng mga matrice
na puno ng mga zero.
Kaya ang bawat isa sa apat na block na ito ay kumakatawan ng isang matrice na may bilang
ng mga hilera at hanay na naaayon sa bilang
ng mga classical state ng Y.
Ang ideya ng isang controlled na operasyon, na natagpuan na natin
sa classical setting kapag tinalakay natin ang isang
controlled NOT na operasyon,
ay kung ang X ay nakatakda sa zero,
wala ang mangyayari sa Y.
Ngunit kung ang X ay nakatakda sa isa,
ang U ay ilalapat sa Y.
Kaya ang X ay tinatawag na control qubit, at ang Y ay tinatawag na target system, na sa pangkalahatan ay hindi
kailangang maging isang qubit.
Para sa isang partikular na halimbawa,
na babanggitin ko lang, mayroon tayong controlled NOT na operasyon.
Kung ang unang qubit ay nakatakda
sa zero, walang nangyayari. At kung ang unang qubit ay nakatakda sa isa, isang NOT na operasyon o katumbas nito,
isang sigma X na operasyon ay
inilalapat sa ikalawang qubit.
At narito ang matrix na representasyon nito.
Pinag-uusapan natin dito ang dalawang qubit, kaya maaari rin tayong magpasya na ang ikalawang qubit ang control at ang
una ang target.
Upang ilarawan ang operasyong iyon, pinapalitan lang natin ang pag-order
sa tensor product, at ang resulta ay ang matrix
na makikita mo dito.
Kung sa halip ng isang controlled-NOT na operasyon, isasaalang-alang natin ang isang controlled sigma
Z o controlled Z na operasyon.
Makukuha natin ang matrix
na representasyong ito dito. At para sa isang ito, hindi talaga mahalaga
kung alin ang control at kung alin ang target.
Parehong resulta ang makukuha natin kahit papaano.
Maaari tayong lumayo pa at isaalang-alang ang isang controlled swap na operasyon.
At dito ay pinag-uusapan natin
ang pagpapalit ng dalawang qubit, kaya nagtatapos tayo sa tatlong qubit kapag kasama ang controlled qubit.
Ang bawat matrix na representasyon
ay mukhang ganito.
Ito ay medyo espesyal na operasyon at kilala ito bilang isang Fredkin na operasyon, o mas karaniwang isang Fredkin gate.
Kapag iniisip natin ito
bilang isang gate sa isang circuit, pag-uusapan natin ang mga circuit sa susunod na aralin.
Ang huling halimbawa ay isang controlled,
controlled-NOT na operasyon, na muli ay isang
operasyon sa tatlong qubit.
At narito ang matrix na representasyon nito. Ang operasyong ito ay mas kilala
bilang isang Toffoli na operasyon o isang Toffoli gate.
Pag-uusapan pa natin ito
at makikita natin kung bakit parehong ito at ang Fredkin gate na operasyon ay napaka-mahalagang
mga operasyon sa isang susunod na aralin.
At iyon ang katapusan ng ikalawang aralin. Sa araling ito, tinalakay natin kung paano gumagana ang quantum information para sa maraming sistema.
Umaasa akong samahan mo ako sa
ikatlong aralin sa lalong madaling panahon, na tungkol sa mga quantum circuit
protocol at laro.
Paalam hanggang sa muli.